[Music]
i love them and we love them and it's
been such a joy it's the collab we never
thought we knew we needed it's a dream
but you know still can't believe it
coldplay and bts joined forces on their
first song together my universe and it
is definitely out of this world
[Music]
[Music]
fans of both bands first heard a brief
snippet of the love song on tick tock
where coldplay frontman chris martin
harmonizes the chorus with the k-pop
band
and since releasing the track chris has
performed it live check out his acoustic
rendition on the kelly clarkson show he
even sings bts's part in korean
that bright infinity inside
and it keeps getting better because the
two superstar groups plan to release a
documentary about the collab titled
inside my universe which is set to drop
september 26th
[Music]
when speaking about the collab with zane
lowe on apple music one chris opened up
about how the new song came about it's a
love song yes
that came from
a loving text it had been in my mind for
a while that someone had said
bts
were wondering if we'd do a song for
them or something something like that
and um
the phrase my universe
in this text was oh that's a cool song
title the 44 year old rock star also
shared what it was like working with the
korean super group and i love them and
we love them and it's been such a joy
it's something you could look at so
cynically and we have at times but
anytime there's actual communication or
or music between us it just feels so
good but of course this isn't the first
time bts is singing in english last year
they released dynamite their first
english full song
[Music]
caught up with bts to celebrate the
track they revealed why singing in
english was important to them
it was a huge
enormous challenge for all of us um
well but you know we but we decided to
do it because you know let's try
something new let's challenge something
in this current situation you know
pandemic so
every i think everyone did well quite
well yeah we first listened to the demo
we just loved it and you know let's keep
it this way and we've done we've done it
you